300 c'est le nombre de tests antigénique
qui devrait être réalisée par jour au
nouveau centre dépistage qu'ovide 19 une
structure stratégiquement placés au
niveau de la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines
les gars il ya souvent des parkings à
côté il ya souvent une bonne desserte de
bus et et c'est aussi parce qu'il reste
encore 50 % des franciliens qui se
déplace le matin dans les transports en
commun la structure d'accueil et de
tester désormais à disposition des
habitants du lundi au vendredi de 13h à
19h un centre met sur pied en une
semaine
ici on avait l'opportunité d'avoir un
local vide j'ai demandé à la communauté
d'agglomération c'est local pouvait
servir façon à accueillir mieux les gens
que dans un barnum
dans la période nous sommes est un
nouveau pas pour contenir la propagation
du virus selon l'agglomération espérait
relancer au plus vite l'activité
économique quand vous travaillez
c'est vrai que vous n'êtes pas dans la
même situation quand vous vous avez peur
quand quand même dans quelqu'un peut le
transmettre la lave ou diminuer les
acteurs de transmission puisque quand
vous le savez vous restez chez vous par
essence vous est pris en charge par un
médecin s'il ya une forte charge virale
6 mai mais a priori c'est aussi de
permettre d'organiser le retour de
l'activité économique normale dont les
yvelines et 8 gare accueille déjà ou
accueilleront prochainement un centre de
dépistage antigénique au total en
ile-de-france 50 grandes gares
franciliennes sont concernés